rip up a [ __ ] chunk of it put it on
me and [ __ ] dive in the corner
pretend I'm part of the turf and tell
them chaos and people like hey there's
more there's more floor to walk on let's
go walk on that floor
[Music]
all right I know how much we hate to
actually report real news here I love
reporting the real news usually it's a
downer no this one's a downer we said
that about the last one dude I don't
know what you're talking about you
refuse to be down to buy this I love
down knees very positive about this guy
that's very good it's important we have
a positive person here also you look
really great in that shirt you look like
an Asian Mr Clean right now oh thank you
I appreciate that this is a Kirkland
Signature is
do it I [ __ ] smelled it I was like
why does that look so quality I didn't
want to ask I'm a big fan of curling
signature
um yeah I have a brand deal coming out
today this month all right so speaking
of curriculum signature that's terrible
um there was an Indonesian football
match that recently just happened oh
like soccer uh yeah soccer would be the
appropriate American soccer dude it's
soccer uh and then right after these two
rival teams if you will kind of like had
their this is the the incident occurred
pretty much after a match between oh man
I'm gonna butcher this per se Baya
Surabaya beautiful at
conjuru Han stadium in Malang Regency
East Java oh [ __ ] Flawless that's pretty
good dude that was not bad right not bad
at all not bad thank you thank you it's
happened last Saturday night
um
everybody the fans started storming the
pitch after the game because people were
like it was an upset people were
unsatisfied you know people started just
like running onto the field is this
professional soccer or kids soccer this
is not kid soccer this is AYSO this is
this is not kid soccer I believe this is
professional soccer but Bart thinks like
thousands of people go to kids soccer
I have a I have a better question I
don't I've always heard people say this
what is the pitch what is that
why are you looking like that
I don't know what the pitch is you mean
just like coming out onto the field
is it is it a field it's a like a
stadium like a soccer a football stadium
oh it's the actual place
okay I hear him said on Ted lasso I
don't know what the [ __ ] that means
we're usually running out onto the field
okay yeah I believe somebody correct me
but just say field then I just said feel
[ __ ]
you only go American you want me to go
Euro let's go Euro America let's go I
want you to try I want you to German
accent my dream is not that good your
German is the best German we have in the
room and I'm German so you give me the
pass no yeah you got the pass and you
can say Nazi as much as you want I love
saying that you can say it so a bunch of
people run onto the field right and then
police and and responders are there and
then they start trying to crowd control
but they start throwing tear gas now
that's against FIFA codes so this is
actually like a endorsed like
professional sporting event at a stadium
but the police are trying to [ __ ]
write control and they're throwing like
tear gas and people started getting
[ __ ] freaked out they start sprinting
towards a particular like exits and and
people start getting crushed and
trampled and they can't breathe and this
ends up being the most horrific accident
and 125 people have been accounted for
as dead at the current moment holy [ __ ]
another great article Anthony
it's the new show we gotta bring the
news here okay oh god dude we all let
people know uh why don't we talk about
Indonesian beaches or something yeah
let's talk about top favorite Indonesian
dishes
this guy's I guess we could yeah we
could just switch it up right now just
talk about food but honestly my biggest
fear is getting crushed to death in a
crowd of people and now we're off the
food part yeah which one do you want
Anthony okay uh either running with the
bulls though have you seen those videos
I hate those videos yeah he's been it
was a very fun time dude I gotta say
though watching like Florida dads in
there is the best [ __ ] ever because
because they're like it's like instant
like they're building themselves up
hiding themselves up like I'm gonna have
an experience you know and then as soon
as [ __ ] starts they're like you can see
the oh [ __ ] like start to take over
their eyes like this is wild yeah like
what the [ __ ] did I get myself into yeah
watching anybody who's like not super
athletic in a very very heightened Human
Experience of just like mob movement is
[ __ ] crazy love it I need to see
dudes with Fat Tuesdays with fat with
fatter guts doing some new balances
white New Balance let's go but
um this got me thinking even as I was
reading this because we had once I think
Ryan brought up an article one time it
might have been
um I don't know if it was like school
shootings or something but like things
to do or in certain situations and just
like mentally like where to put yourself
because as I was reading this I was
thinking about like what what would I do
let's say if I was on the field and then
suddenly things started going crazy
crazy [ __ ] easy you know what I would
do okay I would go to the [ __ ] turf
rip up a [ __ ] chunk of it put it on
me and [ __ ] dive in the corner and
pretend I'm part of the turf until the
chaos and people like hey there's more
there's more floor to walk on that floor
there's that bumpy floor oh wow look at
that floor that floor is completely open
right now run over it run over it
there's all this space but they all
cultivate to this one spot isn't that
the whole point like dirt that's why
you're getting crushed you can't find
floor yeah Bart's killer idea is to
become more floor the remote areas of
the pitch maybe once you move they run
on you maybe like the safe Zone
genuinely the worst problem solving I've
ever heard it's quite the opposite I'm
walking away from the exits try it okay
because that's how you want to get
trampled faster
even better then okay when you're trying
to exit a place you're looking for the
easiest way out right yeah so you go for
the exit right I'll get paint I'll paint
a staircase on me
close to me
hair case still a floor still something
that people walk on the hard way but
he's the worst painter they're like
we'll wait for the elevator thank you
Bart finds a door on the ground he picks
up the door and he holds it and he hides
behind the door he's like oh and then he
and then behind the door he's like oh
God I'm so I'm so lucky I found this
door thank God
there's a big Asian guy in this room
stop on him
the weird thing is that like what you
can't even apply things that like real
protocol to this because the the uh
police did something they weren't
supposed to do apparently yeah yeah
because the FIFA rules or some [ __ ] so
why are they I didn't even know that
there were FIFA rules on how police can
handle riots did you know that I don't
know people I had like superseded yeah
police jurisdiction that's crazy it's
probably because it probably because all
the soccer games get pretty wild don't
they yeah they do get like all the
little hooligans they they'd be trying
to like fight each other all the time
yeah but this more people have died in
this than any of those shits that's
crazy yeah yeah with over 300 other
people being injured like the 320. how
many people are in the stadium you said
oh this is probably like because the
main thing is that tear gas is supposed
to disperse crowds away from where the
gas is but if there's no more floor
gassing the [ __ ] exit where the
crowd's trying to get out and they're
[ __ ] dead and also though we got to
think about this here's where another
problem was the uh they had issued 42
000 tickets for a stadium that holds a
maximum of 38 000 oversold there you go
Asian style but also it's like once
people all go crazy in a crowd
environment you're kind of [ __ ] what
else yeah that's why you don't oversell
that's why you know all these things why
was everyone on the field they got too
hyped basically they're losing uh the
losing team people they just like got
pissed off so they just ran onto the
field which means that the winning team
people also like run onto oh it's one of
those I see and it just turned into a
giant like how the [ __ ] did this
escalate it just cluster functions in
America's terms this is like Eagles fans
if they win or lose yeah either way yeah
either way yeah Philly's [ __ ] they're
destroying the city yeah but yeah even
then there's still ways you can you know
they're still like safe ways to protocol
against that [ __ ] like that's the
closest I've ever been to something like
this was I was at the khabib Conor fight
where khabib jumped the fence still like
whip on Connor oh yeah
if so it's like you know like the UFC is
very structured you have the announcer
come out here is the fight after that
happened Dana White comes out with the
belt like you know what's gonna happen
um when khabib hops the fence and starts
wailing on the dude and in Conor's fight
and the other his teammates are inside
and it's just a big ass Rumble going
into that fight like half the fans were
khabib fans like you could just tell
with like their beards and [ __ ] and then
the other like Nadim style right and
then the other are like fake Connors so
like purple vests like everyone thinks
they're like some Irish like Suave like
mob type dude and when that [ __ ] went
off to the left and right of me everyone
was fighting all in the stands people
just wailing on each other for no reason
no reason and then I go and I'm like
like I'm like oh she get the [ __ ] out of
here when we go into uh behind the
bleachers you know where they have like
all the concessions down there you buy
corn dogs and [ __ ] people just wailing
on each other dude like your husband's
wife they're there they're like they're
hanging out and like I should punch you
in the [ __ ] face
I don't know why they're doing it I'm
gonna [ __ ] choke you out right now I
need a beard somebody give me a beard
the [ __ ] Cooks come out with Cleavers
and [ __ ] they just everyone was wailing
on each other and I was like holy [ __ ]
this is scary because I was also wearing
uh both the khabib hat and a Conor
McGregor shirt because I was a fan of
both oh no because I wore both of them
and I'm like oh yeah I should probably
get the [ __ ] out of here you're like I
need to go pick up some [ __ ] floor
some bar problem solving right linoleum
you can't pick that up was there anybody
on a mic going stop fighting no so what
was crazy is going into that fight keep
fighting already I think they knew
there's gonna be a lot of attention so
these were like the [ __ ] craziest
like super cops I've ever seen you know
like universal Soldier everyone looks
like Michael Jai White and [ __ ] going
into the [ __ ] Stadium like where the
[ __ ] did they find these seven foot
police officers or Jack but they're
already at the bottom I think they could
already uh sense detention and when that
fight broke out they just shut the
lights off over the Octagon to let
everyone know like calm the [ __ ] down
and usually at the end like Dana White
will come out and say Hey thank you
everyone for coming you just see all of
like the big wigs they just all exit
while everyone's still wailing on each
other so like the whole event just ended
unofficially and everyone's still
willing to know each other it was crazy
but you know they're still walking out
they're like this is going to be great
for business yeah for sure sort of a
metaphor for how the world will end
all the rich people just went oh yeah
I'm just gonna peace out into my little
shelter and then we're all gonna kill
each other
[Music]
foreign